it seems so much easier and i'm speaking
from experience
it seems so much easier or at least
much more routine to judge let's just
even say myself
yeah and speak negatively like you know
untethered soul i think it was was like
you'd never be friends with your inner
your inner self like the the things that
you say to yourself like would you ever
be best friends with that person no
we're so hard on ourselves
right um why the heck are we programmed
like that or is this
are we pro i mean why are we hard on
ourselves why would we do that
it's a great question i get it in
different iterations of that i would
assert it's because that's the dimension
we're in
right so for me from my perspective
because looking at the deepest level of
who we are
these limitless spiritual energetic
beings and we've manifested into this
physical meat suit
on a place called planet earth why did
we come here because we had karma to
resolve
and the karma being limitations fears
perceptions of inadequacies
and life one again one of my favorite
quotes a lot of people share
is life will present you with people and
circumstances to reveal where you're not
free
100 so you're always going to attract
whatever it is that you need in order
to be that subtle sort of form of
resistance
and sloughing to be able to remove the
constraints that currently inhibit the
limitlessness of your soul right and
this paradigm is perfect for that so
the language that we use that you cite
is derogatory by virtue of the fact
that's still how we look at ourselves
and it's flip it's it's twofold so
that's how we incarnate like i say we
arrive with our bucket of fears and the
game is who can get rid of them the
first you know the quickest
then you become an inspiration for other
people to do the same
but really it's also without the
constriction
of self-judgment or self-criticism you
don't actually have to learn the
language of love
see it's easy to love the parts of you
that you love it's easy to love the
parts of you that you like or that you
find attractive
but love that is
is able to embrace all of the parts of
you that you think are ugly
is love see love doesn't distinguish
between forms
and so going back to how we sort of
prior to this with talking about love
love that is based on you know well you
do what i want you to do
then i love you that's that's not love
that's conditional tendency that's
preferences yeah
so ironically by virtue of the fact that
we have these narratives and the
dialogues about ourselves that are
derogatory then that part of us
is actually the conduit to which we get
to manifest
what real love is which is being able to
embrace all parts
do we actually ever experience anyone
else
or do we only really actually experience
ourselves and our wounds
our triggers our insecurities our
judgments are
our do we only ever experience ourselves
i know that's like i'm actually jumping
into a concept that's probably
a little too complicated if you haven't
even
like gone there as far as mirroring
triggers projections
wounds try like right so maybe we should
like
back it up before i ask that question do
we ever actually experience anyone else
and like unpack the human experience
okay well that could take a while
um i mean i think the first part of your
question is powerful
it's you know we could argue it depends
how deep you want to go that it's all
us all the way i want to go all the way
okay that's what she said
is this that's an all right yeah we say
whatever the hell we want
it's important to make jokes along the
way when we're saying really big words
and talking about really big concepts
because it
is humanizing and relating really big
things uh
yeah she said that too um
self declared so
so yeah so i guess words are so
imperative like so for you to say do we
really experience anybody else we could
say well what do you mean by do we
really experience right
and this is where i think love and
relationships which is something i've
spoken to a lot recently
is so it's so imperative to understand
because if
in order to be truly connected with
somebody you have to know how to listen
and most people don't know how to listen
because they're listening
through a filter of self-protection
so invariably most people aren't able to
be with another person
fully because by virtue of their brain
which is designed to predict
and protect because it's a survival
mechanism then in
invariably what's actually happening at
a deeper subconscious level is
we're looking out for anything that
could be a perceived threat and now
perceived threat doesn't have to be
someone running at us with a knife or a
saber-toothed tie but
tiger it could be somebody saying
something that is in conflict with our
belief structures
so then we feel the need to defend now
what's actually happening in that
interaction is you're not hearing what
they're saying you're hearing your ears
work you hear the sound
but what it is it's coming up against
something that is so primal in the way
that you relate to yourself in life that
it feels like it's a threat at that
moment there's no connection there's no
relationship and this is why most
relationships don't work
because people don't actually listen
particularly sadly the men
women are much better at that and
holding space for each other so i think
the only way that you could truly get
close to experiencing somebody else
is when you really understand what it
means to listen and listening
is similar to it's an akin to love
because you're holding space for someone
to have their reality
regardless of whether you agree with it
condone it or get it or understand it
doesn't matter
you're understanding that that's their
current reality and it's transitory
right like i was in hawaii doing a
retreat
predominantly women and this one mum
very sweet she said you know how do i
help my son who's always speaking
negatively about himself and especially
as it relates to his older brother
he kept saying you know i'm never going
to be as good as jimmy and
and um she would she went on to say you
know i'm telling him he's
all his attributes all of his skills
like no but you're amazing and you're
this and you're kind and you're that
and i said but you're not listening to
him and you know it was quite
confronting for her for me to just be
that blatant with her
and i said i think she's doing it right
right she's being a mom and she loves
her son and i got it i understand
her reality but it's a superimposition
of her view on top of his
which is a form of demand and
manipulation
um so she she was amazing she was such a
trooper and i said so i just want you to
consider your son is saying what he's
saying and that's his reality now i
understand you don't want him to hang
out in this world of demise and
insufficiency but that is his reality
and the degree to which you're not
meeting him there is the degree to which
it's being perpetuated
and she's like oh my god and and she
said you know what's funny he's always
telling me i don't listen
i said well apparently he's pretty
astute you know so
she but it was so powerful she had a
tear in her eye because i said listen
i of course with you want him to feel a
sense of worth and
for his perception relative to his
brother to be enhanced and so that he
doesn't feel inadequate
but until such time that you honor
somebody's reality for where they are
right now
there is no shift there is no
transformation so she really got it she
said wow that's so powerful
then you can get into his world which
would be the closest to getting to
experience somebody and say
well why do you feel that where did that
start what happened
versus you superimposing your view on
someone else's
you she got to have the opportunity to
understand why he felt that way
at the end of our interaction she was
really sporty and you know everybody got
so much from it in the group
which is often the case when i'm working
with someone one-on-one
i said here's my invitation to you
go meet your son and that's when the
you know the tears really started
rolling because she loves him but she
hadn't really met him
the being yeah you know so and she sent
me a beautiful email a couple of
uh weeks after she's like you know our
relationship is
night and day